[Music]
yes I
agree I
agree happy Wednesday everybody so every
now and then you see something that
captures why things everywhere seem to
be falling apart these
days no not just that I'm talking about
a theory called chesterton's fence the
rule of chesterton's fence never destroy
a fence change a rule or do away with a
tradition until you understand why it
was there in the first place I would
also add removing your breast
implants wow dead crowd tonight
huh a lot of breast implants yeah but
that's good advice on par with don't
poop where you eat which is why Joe
Biden no longer has lunch in the Oval
Office
you don't deserve that joke but GK
chesterton's rule goes to the heart of
all this chaos many social constructs
that have held things together really
come down to fences metaphorical and
literal fences and rules backed by
Western values that helped preserve
order and make for a good life it wasn't
perfect but it was a hell of a lot
better than the Alternatives offered by
dictators in Europe Asia or the third
world but as the US continues to Fumble
on the world stage and our campuses ring
with the chance of hey hey ho ho Western
Civ has got to go the fences are coming
down faster than Hunter Biden's pants at
a cheerleading
camp and what's filling that space is a
Mindless tribal progressivism that's
anything but progress The Barbarians are
at the gates because we got rid of the
gates in Israel for instance the
construction of a literal fence ended
years of Terror attacks launched from
the West Bank in Gaza the first thing
breached by Hamas was a 25m long fence
separating the Israelis and Palestinians
but was also breached was a fence that
was also an idea the idea that western
style democracy is preferable to a
society ruled by a corrupt military
cabal who makes Saddam Hussein look like
Sandy
Duncan it was two tribes separated by
fences but also by centuries it'd be
like if George Jetson built a mansion
next to The Flintstones and so of course
the America hating Western woke elit
side against whatever's been working
best which makes Israel the oppressors
and Hamas the resistance but have they
thought this through do they actually
want to export hamas's system elsewhere
to Hamas Savages LGBT stands for Let's
Go bomb and terrorize it's the same here
at home as most of us try to conserve
rules and traditions that have made the
American system the most successful ever
regressive
progressivism regressive progressives
are are looking to tear down the fences
of capitalism and Law and Order in favor
of fundamental change and it's changing
all right what you're seeing in the
streets is what the fence kept at Bay
simplistic amoral protests based on
lineage and tribal Warfare following the
death of George Floyd our entire
criminal justice system was pegged as
institutionally racist so cash bail went
away shoplifting became reparations 40
acres in a mule became 10 men in speed
sticks and 15 tubes of pepsodent defund
and decarceration became delightful is
it working we'll put it this way anybody
out there want to buy a bachelor pad in
Manhattan I promise I'll have it
fumigated so what happens when you tear
down the fence known as criminal justice
well you get New York Philly Baltimore
Washington San Fran La Portland Seattle
Memphis Houston Austin I could keep
going but if I do I'm going to sound
like stepen Hawking by the time I'm done
is this really what the Dems want Coast
to Coast one big giant pile
of and there's our Southern border the
bit of fence with holes you could drive
the cast of The View through President
Biden is more terrified of his party's
left wing than he is of stairs so any
notion of defining the idea of the
United States is you guessed it
institutionally racist if that's true
then every nation on Earth is
institutionally racist now it's right
about here where a liberal would say
Greg you're just an entitled privilege
cracker what about all the impoverished
black and brown people in the world do
you think they feel that way to which I
would brilliantly reply why don't you
ask them yourself as they pour over our
Southern border by the millions to live
in the country that you hate so much
we're even dismantling the border
between genders personally I'm okay with
a fence between the Sexes although
there's always some genders no fence can
contain but if there's no border that
defines the Sexes you get a generation
of disillusioned unproductive people
people living in isolation and denial so
if you think about it much of
civilization up to the modern age has
been a war against regressive tribalism
we created republics of laws and
freedoms that were imperfect but they
were there for a reason and now we have
a generation deciding that the fences
must come down never mind their initial
necessity now to have a good life you do
need a structure but sadly you get no
reward when that structure works because
how do you show the bad things things
that just stopped if they never really
occurred so the young and naive have a
choice between an imperfect unprovable
good and the evil it holds it Bay and
they choose evil without fail perhaps
it's the result of a country so
successful and decadent it leaves bored
Minds to embrace suicidal ideas and so
they tear down structures without
contemplating their existence in the
first place that's chesterton's law
which reminds me of gutfeld's law which
is some people are just remarkably
irredeemably and hopelessly
stupid and to those I say stay on your
side of the
fence
perod let's welcome tonight's guests
she's known as the bad girl in her Bible
study group host of Fox News Sunday
Shannon
Bree he loves cooking his lials medium
rare chef and restaurant tour Andrew
gruel
it's her eighth straight year being at
the top of the naughty list New York
Times bestselling author and fox
contributor
katum and he prefers to do his nut
cracking year round New York Times
bestselling author comedian and former
NBA world champion
[Music]
Tyrus you mean any number of things yes
I meant that in a wholesome way I'm so
not a
nutcracker Shannon I'm sure you're a fan
of Chesterton what is the whole purp
purpose for offense why is there offense
at all well don't you feel like it's
healthy to ask those questions everybody
at some point is going to push back
against things they don't understand
they don't like especially as a kid I
think about when I was like seven and
one of my mom's pillars of Western
civilization was you could not eat ice
cream for breakfast every day and I'm
like well why not because she was also a
teacher at my school I'm not sending in
like a second grade Tasmanian Devil to
embarrass me in front of all these
people also you don't want to end up on
600 lb life is one of the best shows yes
I love that show I like how you
condition that you don't want to get any
angry letters from no no I love that
show I'm actually a little bit obsessed
with it but I'm asking why why why why
at least if people I worry about if you
are so deadset on on an end result that
you can't even ask why something exists
in the first place so you're arguing
against fences no I'm asking that you
should at least ask why the fence is
there no good question before you get
rid of it good point way over my head
Shannon as usual Andrew so you work as a
chef are there quote metaphorical fences
and walls that you have in place to
protect from absurd trends like what if
somebody says you know Foods don't
necessarily have to taste good to be
cooked and served I mean they're doing
that with insects yeah that's a great
question food is racism but the uh the
pizza right let's take pizza so Pizza
classic Italian pizza you just got
cheese maybe throw on pepperoni one
topping now we got like a pickled
elephant nipple pizza coming out of you
know this really woke Pizzeria down on
the Lower East Side and and also I I
should say off topic to that question
that 5 seconds ago I realized what a
horrible father I am because my kids had
uh ice cream for breakfast today so uh
that I wish I was your kid I you should
well they're probably out there ripping
the fence apart right now just out of
out of the sugar high but uh you know
these I've said fence so many times
after reading about chesterton's Theory
and I also want to smoke a Chesterton
but um you know I also think that this
Theory kind of when you look at it from
the reverse applies to the federal
government right and I know the burden
of proof lies on those who want to
destroy the fence but like the
government has put these fences up and
we got to remove some of those fences so
I think when it comes to the morons out
there on the street who are protesting
for whatever reason that they don't even
know or understand they just need to get
out of the way but when it comes to the
government we got to remove some of
those fences that are there because
they're
insignificant cat that's an interesting
point on the one hand it is hard to
prove whether your your fence works
because you never know the bad thing
that you caused because it didn't happen
but in the same respect with some fences
you don't know if they're actually
working at all yeah I think that there's
two nobody's doing anything about any
fences yeah I think people just yell at
each other this fence is all your fault
uh I don't there's there's not
examination going on um but it would be
helpful if there was I think but like
Shannon your question is great you
should know why it's there you should be
thoughtfully considering it but rather
than thoughtfully considering anything
people try to think of why it's not
their fault so then they don't have to
do anything because it's not your fault
if you don't consider it then you won't
end up realizing that you might be doing
something wrong and that you might need
to change something about yourself mhm
if you look at every Avenue of turmoil
Tyrus social discourse history crime
biology the the decline begins when
previous foundations are destroyed
without asking why well here's the thing
and and obviously he's a brilliant man
but his his theories are flawed mhm and
yeah that's right I'm saying it you're
going after I'm going going after chest
because here's why and this this what
I'm just looking at from a street
perspective right he has another several
but one that always stood out to me he
has about a Street Lamp M Street lamps
in the middle of the city is light it's
bright some people think it's too bright
needs to go other people it's the only
light they have they want to go to and
again both his stories whether it's the
fence the street line are all based on
looking to wisdom MH before you
react so there is a wise great man in
charge of the fence and when they go to
the fence they ask I want to tear it
down he goes you know why the fence was
built no go away and come back mhm with
the Street Lamp it was a monk who was at
telling them but here's the thing this
new genre does not seek wisdom they
don't look to leadership and they're
being they're coming up with the
understanding that I can attack there's
no consequences there's no
accountability so I don't give a damn
what the fence was for all I know it's
in my way and I don't like it and we as
a group the group Think Tank the mob
doesn't stop they run the wise old man
over and Lynch him and call him a racist
and drag the wrap the fence around his
neck because no one seeks wisdom with
these groups when when you bring this up
with octob they knew the fence in in
Gaza they crossed it with and they that
fence was to protect them from Israel
Israel and vice versa you RI the fence
down you created Massacre now the fence
is down for them too yes you never once
thought oh hey guess what's coming back
but see they didn't stop to ask the wise
men before we do this what would happen
they would say Israel's going to release
hell on Earth on you MH they didn't care
because the new way of the world is
there's no consequences they went from
Monsters to heroes in a news cycle
because no one seeks the wisdom anymore
that's the problem with his just put it
out there you are
yeah Tyrus is fox's GK Chesterton hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else